hey everyone this is Steve watchop with
collider and I am here in the collider
Sundance Studio sponsored by Saratoga
Spring Water I want to give a huge thank
you to them because uh Sundance
attending Sundance is expensive and we
appreciate our sponsors so I will say
thank you to Saratoga
um I'm thrilled to be with the cast and
filmmakers behind and I want to make
sure I get this right aliens abducted my
parents and now I feel left out kinda
left out see I already knew I was going
to mess that up
um it's a big title
um was so someone who runs a website say
me it's hard when a movie is that long
of a title because it takes up a lot of
space did you get any like feedback
saying hey do you you feel this strongly
about the long title for sure I think
the thing about it though is that when
Austin pitched the movie to me Austin
wrote the movie and when you pitched it
to me that's all he said was the title
and I don't know I mean that's the log
line like you know everything about the
movie from that so we were like well we
can't change it it's also I mean it
sticks in your brain so people have been
like I don't know maybe we Workshop it a
little bit but Austin and I have kind of
always been like no that's it that's the
title we don't care about the Steves of
the world right or the websites or the
I'm gonna I'm gonna use a more term the
SEO of the world right because yes that
was a little bit of a misstep so maybe
we do care about that no I mean you know
something though it is I agree with you
though when you hear the title you know
what the movie is like you you know what
I mean so everyone watching this
congrats for being part of Sundance but
everyone watching will not have seen the
movie yet so I guess Austin or Jake who
wants to bite the bullet and say the how
have you been describing the film to
friends and family Austin does
I start with the title I say well it's
about a boy who believes his uh he saw
his parents get abducted by aliens and
he's not even mad about it he just it's
kind of bummed that they didn't take him
with him uh and then in walks itsy this
girl from the big city uh who meets this
boy and they have they share this
similar want which is to get out of this
small town and go and do something else
uh and that and that's and that's
basically everything is a spoiler to a
degree I mean everything everything
apart from the title is a spoiler so
uh so I guess the big question is um I'm
a big fan of Will's work and um why
wouldn't you be so uh how often on set
did you quote mcgruber or talk about
mcgruber or any of Will's past work
uh here's the beautiful thing we made
this movie in such a quick amount of
time that will came in and out in a
blink of an eye and we had like 80 pages
to shoot while he was there so there was
like so little time to quote mcgruber
but what I will say is that well there
were a lot of kids there were I mean
it's a kids movie but we did we went to
his trailer once and he showed us some
scenes from the mcgruber TV show that
hadn't come out yet and that was the
highlight of the movie for me right
one of the things about this film though
is it's appropriate for all ages uh
anyone can watch it and so for the
actors can you sort of talk about is
that one of the things that Drew you to
the project
uh yeah I think I think for me I love
that family-friendly aspect but I feel
like a lot of those films kind of push
aside emotions which I feel like a lot
of kids do feel but this one kind of
dives into that and dives into the
loneliness and and really shows kids
that they have more to offer than just
the people around them and whether
they're there or not
yeah for me it was the like comedy of it
I've never done anything so comedic is
this movie and I learned my flaws that I
can't keep a still face in a scene so I
ruined so many takes by laughing because
everyone here is just hilarious
for you guys what was it about the
script or story that said I want to do
this I've I got to know uh Jake over
well like 10 years ago he was a PA on
the movie Don verdeen and there was a
day that I think the schedule changed
around and so we ended up just walking
around the streets the tiniest little
tiny town in Utah yeah and then and then
years later we uh they invited me to do
their show he and McLean called
show-offs and and I became friends with
them and then I came and did Studio C
both of them for BYU TV and so at that
point when we were doing Studio C he
said uh you know do you want to be a
part of this movie and I basically I
didn't know anything about the script at
that point and I think I just said yes
yeah just because these guys are great
and it was the experience of working
with them and it's and I've done a lot
of very dirty stuff in my life and I
just had kids and it's like he's they're
very amazing at creating this
very it's a type of absurd a clean
absurdity that's so fun and interesting
and that it just it's I have a lot of
respect for it because I I don't know
it's hard for like I you know you take
away the the dirtiness from stuff and
sometimes you know I don't know I don't
I don't have much so so with the the
fact that he can do such funny stuff in
a clean way is very uh exhilarating and
and I was just excited to be a part of
it and I have two little little
daughters now so it's fun to be in
something they can watch
clean absurdity do you love that that's
your name I describe yourself I can
listen to you guys talk about this movie
all day great question
um my friend Bob called and said do you
want to work with some of the greatest
guys in this business and I said sure
that was it and then I read the script
and it was it was so quirky and charming
and true and lovely and um I felt like
it was good
I'm curious though you have a a big
scene like I would imagine you were this
is one of these things where you are in
and out of this project and so and you
have a big scene and a diner and I'm
curious what is it like when you're
stepping foot on set where everyone's
been shooting already and you need to
make you need to do it all like
everything about your character in a
short amount of time oh I loved it I
mean it was the most welcoming set you
guys were spectacular I came to set I
got hugs I got oh my gosh we're so happy
you're here I heard we're so happy
you're here probably like 15 times with
hugs with what can I get you would you
like to sit here and I was like this is
nice like I have a teenager at home I'm
not treated like that so I felt like it
was great and I loved and the character
was so beautifully drawn it felt um I
know it felt like a joy one of the
things I also liked is that itsy's
parents are very supportive it is not a
um you know what I mean like it's
unusual so can you sort of talk about
that aspect um if you want to talk about
it yeah
yeah it was really fun to work with like
kind of like in it and out of it pretty
quickly so it was really fun to get to
know them and then get to know itsy and
how she has so much like range of what
she can do and like she gets grounded
and then she's like leaving because
she's never been grounded you know like
she she has her life to herself and
they're just kind of watching her and so
that made a movie
I think also we we wanted to make the
parents feel kind of like 80s parents we
didn't want the parents to be we the
stories about these two teenagers and so
we wanted to have the parents be like
there as much as they needed to be
parental figures but also the idea was
that it's the movies about the kid and
so we're kind of letting them just come
in and out and and be supportive but
also be a little bit aloof like we saw
in those like 80s movies oh no 100 the
parents just love each other so much
they're so obsessed with each other a
lot of the times that they kind of are
on their own having their own little
adventure and we liked having parents
that are you know like
they love each other and they're kind of
in their own little world and that was
fun for us rather than having like
parents that are just fighting or having
conflict all the time it felt natural to
have these parents be so excited about
moving to this you know small town and
doing you know the Fixer-Upper dreams so
they that kind of just worked on its own
I'm curious about the space suit
um and when you first saw it wearing it
and also the lab
yeah so that spacesuit is pretty dang
cool it's it's got tons and tons of
layers of like a bucket that was sawed
out so I could put my arms through that
comes over and has little buttons on it
and then it was like a biker helmet that
was painted and um and that was pretty
fun also the goo that you have to
that was fun and I got so much it was it
was Landry that I got that all over okay
that that was a very fun scene and that
suit was definitely
physical comedy I think is the best way
to put it yeah is it one of those things
where you tried to borrow it from set
and people said f that you know I wish I
could because I imagine if you could go
snowboarding in that just slap that on
put on your helmet well I I think to be
honest it was a snowboarding suit that
was converted into really it was it was
um uh I'm just thinking about that I'm
like but that that that's called um
having a budget and you need to you know
do whatever you can too but that
actually is my next thing so obviously
this is not a Marvel movie you have a
finite schedule and a finite budget what
ended up being the toughest stuff to
pull off with the you know what you were
up against well I think in general the
this I mean we were really shooting a
lot of pages every day we shot the film
and not a huge amount of time we're
talking 14 days or 25 15. 15 days
exactly yes uh exactly and so truthfully
like when will and Elizabeth were there
we had to pack in every single scene
that they were in in those two days and
so that was probably the toughest thing
I will say though that the crew that we
have we shot this locally in Utah and
the crew we have are so inventive and
they have done such that's me and I'm
very sorry so it's allowed right okay
um no they're just just so good at being
inventive and they beg borrowed and
stole things from other sets and from
other things that they had done and so
that was able we were able to put a lot
of stuff on the screen that way uh
another this is another director
question and I'm apologize I'll take it
from here guys right
but I am curious because listen I'm
obsessed with the editing process
because that's where the film comes
together so how did the film change in
the editing room in ways you didn't
expect or what did you did you show the
movie to people and they said oh you
need to fix this yes there were I mean
there was nothing egregious that people
were like uh oh this doesn't work I the
first cut I got back though was like 74
minutes and I was like oh no what have I
done and it just took a little bit of
like finessing and pacing it was just a
little bit tight and so we just opened
it up a little bit and I think that was
the biggest thing is making sure that
the pacing was right because there are
such like heartfelt moments in the movie
and there are also like comedic moments
and so that was the biggest thing is
finding the balance and the in the
transitions in and out of those scenes
to make sure we weren't like whoa this
is all over the place it flows a little
bit more you guys are obviously part of
the Sundance Film Festival oftentimes
you find out at the last minute or you
find out way in advance enough to keep
the secret so for all of you did you
when did you find out and how long did
you were you not able to tell anyone
I mean I'll just be because I got the
call first I'll just start and then I'll
be quiet for the rest of the interview
but um I was on another movie in Ireland
in December and got a phone call at like
three in the morning and didn't get it
till I woke up and I texted the number
because it didn't recognize it and was
like hey sorry I missed your call
um I'm awake now or something and then
it was Kim the senior programmer for
Sundance and she called me right away
and was like hey it was midnight for her
at that point she was like I just was so
excited I wanted to tell you and I was
all alone in this room in Ireland and
was just shouting and screaming I was
like my this movie Alien movie and she's
like yeah we loved it and so then I got
to call the other producers on the film
and wake them up and Austin was in I
kept calling and texting and he's like
called me because it was midnight it was
midnight and so I'm in then my phone
starts buzzing and I look and it's Jake
and so I silenced it and put it back
down because I wasn't gonna answer it so
he called wow right and again I silenced
it and then I hear a text and he I read
it and he goes are you awake and so I
texted and I was like No And I put it
back down and then he called when he
called me the third time I picked it up
and I literally sat up and I was like I
think we just got into Sundance and so I
answered the phone and I was like do you
know that it's midnight he goes I know
buddy but the Sundance Institute just
called we got in and then we just
started laughing we just started it was
a lot of laughing yeah
it was like noon for me but I was still
sleeping so yeah that's true we texted
her and we're like hey can we talk and
she's like yes and she's like we
FaceTime her and she's like oh they
didn't look like this messy I'm still in
bed and they tell me I'm like you're
kicking me and then I like hang up and I
run and I tell my parents and I didn't
keep it a secret I told everyone I knew
I don't know you're supposed to do that
but next time yeah yeah
I pretty much found out like around noon
as well just got a text being like hey
could we hop on a zoom got on and and
found out that way just a random day
being told I was about 11 55 a.m
probably the first sounds like the first
he was yeah it does sound like you were
the first call no I remember being I was
just so excited I don't know about like
you just this was
you don't I didn't sign up for this
thing going oh this is an obvious
Sundance you know it was just so great
because it
she said everyone who's a part of this
was just so
welcoming inviting good at what they did
and and it was just I was just so happy
to be a part of it and and and just to
to know that this came out of it was so
I was just so thrilled for everybody
I found out after everyone else and and
way after I don't know if that's true
but I'm gonna say since you were first I
get to be last at something and um and I
was on a set and I got a call I got a
text saying pick up your phone same
thing right
um we have and then McLean called and
said we got into Sundance and I was like
wait wait what what movie really
Sundance and I was like I was like for
our little sweet movie and they're like
yeah and I was like oh and then it was
it was late and it was a quiet night and
I started dancing around in the street
and they and the little security guys
like you can't do that okay but I was it
was there was Joy it was real Joy
um first of all thank you all for
sharing those are some great stories I
love it when it's stories like this
um we're almost out of time I have to
ask maybe an individual question or two
uh will I have an individual question um
I'm so curious about coyote versus Acme
which is not something that is obviously
this movie because it's CG live action
you're doing something with John Cena so
what can you tell people about it
because it sounds like it could be cool
oh it's I mean
it was so fun to make this it's a it's a
a movie about uh
it came out of this article that I think
is decades old that was uh uh Wiley
Coyote is is suing the Acme corporation
uh because of all the you know different
things that you know
Contraptions that have exploded in his
face and stuff like that and so I get to
play Wiley Coyote's lawyer and it's a
mixture of of animation and it's kind of
like a Who Framed Roger Rabbit Style
movie and yeah John Cena is so great in
it uh I mean it's just a lot of condors
and it's it was so much fun making it
and these guys who are making it are so
smart
they just had because you've got a
figure out where this
animated character is going to move to I
was just it was amazing to be a part of
it so I'm excited to to see how it turns
out because of course you know what I'm
I'm acting with a tennis ball a lot of
times there's the tennis ball for an eye
line and it's moving around so yeah I
think uh I don't know how much more I
can say about it but that's kind of
blathered on it for a while it's
interesting because Roger Rabbit is such
an amazing movie and you like recently
obviously Chippendale came out uh and
which is fantastic if you haven't seen
it on Disney plus uh and look but that's
you know what I mean like I'm glad that
this genre is being further explored
rather than
um being pushed to the weight because
it's anyway Roger Rabbit did such an
amazing job no I mean there are so many
different characters from that universe
that are involved it was a real honor to
get to like act with all these beloved
cartoon characters
Elizabeth have to ask you when you
signed on to play Mrs Claus did you ever
think this is really going to be
something I play for a while 20 years
right yeah 20 years I didn't
not at all I was so excited to do it it
was one of my first big movies and I
thought I thought well yeah yay I didn't
think about it for a second so 20 years
later it's wonderful yeah if we had more
time I would also spend a lot more time
talking about the expanse I'm just going
to say how much I love that show and I'm
going to move on uh so I believe and I
could be wrong that you recently worked
with someone named Merrell or am I did I
am I getting this wrong like Meryl
Streep when I was nine
so yeah but that's amazing are you not
11 how old are you just a little bit
older than that yeah no but I am curious
what it's like when you I said it wrong
when I did it but like what is it like
when you work with someone like that and
when you're at that age do you realize
who you're working with not at all and
it's so weird because like when I was a
kid I did like these huge movies back to
back and I was like clueless like the
only person I knew was Robert Downey Jr
because it's Iron Man but it's like only
now that I can like be like oh my God I
worked with Robert Downey Jr and Meryl
Streep and I didn't even know and they
were just in the corner and I was like
doing whatever so it's weird it's really
weird but it's an interesting story and
it's so weird to look back and just be
like I had no clue what I was doing but
yeah it's pretty cool but you know what
I mean though because like like you're
saying when you're looking back it has
to be yeah it just has to be a very
weird kind of a thing you know no it's
so weird and like Jeff Bridges was a
part of that movie too and like I didn't
know who that was when I was like nine
and I should have but I didn't no but
you shouldn't yeah yeah like when I was
when I was nine I was playing with toys
the fact that you were doing anything
you know what I mean so it was weird and
it's really fun to look back and
sometimes I'll just like watch the
movies to be like that actually happened
that's so weird like it doesn't work it
doesn't make sense uh someone was also
on a show called Let the Right One In
which I believe the whole first season
is wrapped or is it is the last episode
coming yeah no it's completely out first
season is completely out so talk a
little bit about the experience of
making that because
um it also like is there any word on
doing another season like what yeah so
not quite sure about a new season but
that was a big experience because right
after finishing this film I turned 18
moved to New York alone and did my first
Prosthetics role where I was a vampire
and kind of like yeah a lot of kind of
crazy stuff
um very different from this film I will
say and and yes yes but it it really was
such a blast and I actually worked with
Grace Gummer Meryl Streep's daughter as
my sister and um yeah so that that was
really such a blast just being able to
work with so many phenomenal people
across the U.S
um listen I could ask you I had other
questions but I have to wrap and I'm
just going to say sincerely congrats so
happy for you guys and have a fantastic
Sundance